spirea van hoodie eye  probably old-fashioned spirea that  you'll see in everybody's front yard  persisting for many many years this is a  three to four foot arching shrub that  has  nice white flowers in the early spring  one of the things that really  distinguishes  van hoodie eye for me is the almost  rhombic  rhomboid shell shaped leaf of the van  hoodie eye and  with teeth or serrations right at the  terminal part  so it's a very distinctive leaf small  but rhombic and with teeth at the  terminal if it flowered well you might  also see as with the other spireas  some persistent fruit or seeds  holding on during the the winter months  this is a very common shrub the spirea  van hoot  and so you'll see this in most front  gardens of houses  in the urban areas